빌사남이 간다 오늘은 서울시의
대표적인 상권이었다 이대역에 왔습니다
[음악]
어 이대역 상권은 전성기 시절에 정말
2대 5살로 간다로 할 정도로
옷가게들이 굉장히 좀 많아졌고 상권이
되게 활성화돼 있는 그런
지역이었습니다 스타벅스 국내 1호점이
2대역 앞에 들어올 정도로 2대역
상권이 매우 좋았었어요 그러다가 계속
상권이 죽기 시작했고 소비 트렌드가
좀 변하면서 여기에 있는 상권이 계속
붙기 시작했습니다 근데 잠깐
2010년도에 중국인 관광객들이 좀
늘어나면서 다시 살아날 것처럼 보이긴
했지만 중국의 관광객이 또 이제
빠지면서 여기 상권이 더 좀 되게
세트하고 됐습니다서 인근에 상권이 안
좋다 보니까 이제 오피스텔로 신축하는
건물들이 되게 많아졌습니다 일단
상권이 죽은 이유가 있는데 일단 첫
번째로 오프라인 매장들이 다 이제
온라인 매장으로 좀 바뀌었습니다
그래서 옷을 저희가 오프라인 매장
가서 사는 거보다는 이제 온라인 예를
들어서 무신사는 온라인으로 이렇게
옷을 사는 경우가 되게 많 졌거든요
그래서 이제 좀 소비 트렌드가 좀
변화된 부분이 있고 그 두 번째로는
여기 이대역이랑 홍대입구역이 그렇게
멀지가 않아요 한 두정 거상 거리에
위치하고 있어 가지고 여기 상권을 다
빨아 들렸습니다 홍대 입구가 그래서
여기 있는 사람들도 상권을 이용하려고
아니면 친구를 만나려고 다 홍대
입구로 많이 몰리면서 여기 상권이 더
죽은 요인도 좀 있는 거 같습니다
신천도 좀 비슷한 거 같아요 신천도
홍대 여기랑 좀 가깝다 보니까 거기
홍대 입구 상권이 다
빨아들였다 단어가 돈을 많이 벌어
준다라는 그런 뜻이 있다고 합니다
그래서 이대 앞에서 이렇게 사진을 좀
많이 찍었거든요 중국인 관람객들은
그런 중국인 관광객들도 다 이제
홍대라 이런 큰 상권으로 좀 많이
이동을 했어요 그래서 이쪽으로 좀 안
오기 시작했습니다 그네 번째로는
여기가 그 지구단위 계획이 걸려
있었어요 그래서 업종 제한이 있을수
그래서 예를 들어서 가게라 뭐
미용실이라 이런 업종 밖에 안 되는
곳이었어요네 그런 것 때문에 술도
먹고 뭐 거기서 뭐 쇼핑도 하고 막
이렇게 다 이제 이루어져야 되는데
용도 제한 때문에 좀 상권이
활성화되기 좀 어려운 건이었습니다네
마지막 다섯 번째는 여기 이대역
상권에 좀 뜬금없는 건물이 있습니다
spm 건물 앞에 같은 경우에도 여기
공원이 되게 좋거든요 좀 저럼 너무
상업적인 건물이 좀 저는 되게 아쉬운
거 같아요 차라리 저기 다가 좀 약간
이대를 상징할 만한 그런 건축물
아니면 공간을 좀 만들었으면 다른
사람들이 그래도 이대 올 이후가 좀
있거든요 근데 갑자기 어디를 가든 다
볼 수 있는 저런 상업적인 건물이
들어와서 좀 특색이 없는 거 같습니다
외부인들이 왔을 때 다른 상권과 좀
다른 어 그런 부분들을 좀 여기
상권에서 좀 찾는다 그러면 이대
상권이 조금 더 살아나지 않을까네
그렇게 좀 예상하고
있습니다 그 를 좀 말씀드릴 건데
아마이 매각 사례가 좀 이대역 상권에
뭔가 변천 사라지 설명을 드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다 어 2010년도에
3억 8천에 매각된 차례인데 이거를
이제 매입해서 16년도에 15억에
매각을 했습니다 근데 사실 취득세
감안하면 차액이 발생되거나 그러진
않았어요 그러다가 16년도에 매입하실
분을 23년도 어 14억 7천에
매각을 했습니다 취득세도 감안하면
정말 손해가 좀 엄청 큰 거고 무려
7년 동안 시세가 많 오르지
않았습니다 이거를 매입하실 분은
건물이다 철거돼 있을 거야 옆에
건물도 다 이제 철거를 해 가지고
아마 이제 다 같이 묶어서 지을
예정인 거 같은데 지금 여기가 용도
지역이 상업 지거든요네 그래서 건물을
되게 높게 올릴 수 있습니다 그래서
아마 그것도 다 묶어서 이렇게
오피스텔로 신축하지 않을까 그렇게
예상을 좀 하고 있는데 그래도 여기가
이제 상업지 치고 좀 저렴하고 대학생
수요뿐만 아니라 그 직장의 수요도 좀
많은 곳이에요 여기는 그래도 오피스
지으면 그래도 수요가 꽤 있는
지역입니다 아마 그거를 좀 목적으로
땅을 묶어서 신축하지 않을까 그렇게
예상을 하고
있습니다네 그래서 이대역 투자는 정말
솔직하게 말씀드리자면 정말 등
투자하기 좀 쉽지 않은 것 같습니다
그래서 지금 또 워낙 죽었다라는
인식이 너무 커 가지고 다시 살아나
기가 좀 쉽지 않을 것 같아요 2대
상권이 좀 살아나려면 좀 특색 있는
뭔가 상권이 돼야 되고 거기에 이제
또 잘하는 그런 플레이어들이 좀 많이
들어와 될 거 같아요네 그래서 장사를
잘하는 임차인들이 좀 많이 들어와야
되는데 일단 그분들이 들어오게끔
임대료도 좀 많이 낮춰 줘야 될 거
같아요 그 임차인들이 잘 장사를 할
수 있게 뭔가 환경을 좀 만들어 줘야
된다라고 생각을 하고 무엇보다
마케팅을 되게 잘해야 된다라고 생각을
하거든요 여기 지금 뭐 해당
자치구뿐만 아니라 임차인들이 그지
건물주 분도 좀 합심을 해 가지고 좀
SNS 마케팅이라는 모스타
마케팅이라는 뭐 유튜브 마케팅이라
틱톡 마케팅이라 외국인들이 뭔가
이대를 올만한 그런 이유를 좀 만들어
줘야 되거든요 마케팅을 좀 다양하고
심을 해가지고 좀 이대역 상권을
살릴만한 그런 마케팅을 좀 많이
생각해야 될 것
같습니다서 이대역 뭐 상권 좀 전망을
개인적으로 얘기하자면 일단은 홍대라는
너무 큰 상권이 있어요 이대만 뭔가
특색 있는 요소가 있어야지 뭐 이대역
상권이 좀 살아날 거라고 저 예상이
되고 그리고 저는 또 한 가지 보는게
오피스텔 건물이 너무 많아졌습니다
그래서 오피스텔에 뭐 1층이나 뭐
2층에 이제 상가가 들어오는 경우가
있는데 대부분 다 보면은 뭐
부동산이라는 뭐 세탁소 아든 뭐
편의점이라는 이런 오피스텔에 있는
상가들이 좀 많이 들어와요 그러면
거기에 있는 분만 상권을 이용하지
외부인들이 여기에 굳이 올 이유가
없습니다 외부인들이 왔을 때 요즘에는
좀 새로운 경험을 하고 싶어 하거든요
되게 아기자기한 건물들도 많
이게 색 있는 공간도 있고 새로운
경험을 하고 싶은데 와서 다 이제
오피스텔 건물밖에 없으니까가 업종도
좀 되게 제한적으로 있고 외부인들이
더 되게 오기 좀 어렵지 않을까네
그렇게 예상을 합니다 최근에 이제
이쪽대 상권을 좀 살리려고 저기 박스
스퀘어라 지구 단위계획 이제 변경도
될 예정이고 여기가 어떻게 좀 변할지
한번 좀 지켜보면 좋을 거
같습니다 오늘은 좀대 상을 좀
둘러봤는데 우리 영상이 마음에
드셨다면 어 구독과 좋아요 알림
설정까지 좀 부탁드리고 그리고 만약에
궁금하신 상권 있다라고 하면 댓글
남겨 주시면 제가 오늘 같이 이렇게
찾아가서 좀 전체적으로 분석이라 투자
사례라는 어떻게 좀 변화하고 있는지
그리 앞으로 어떻게 될 건지 전망에
대해서도 좀 다뤄보도록 하겠습니다
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 어
빌딩은 사람
[음악]
all so many
times Try to find my
peace